conti
bienvenue à tous bonjour emmanuel
bonjour m il est ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo retour sur les temps forts qui ont
marqué la semaine politique avec tout
d'abord ce vent de panique venus du
mexique la grippe porcine affole le
monde l oms l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
en france l'elysée suit la sphère de
très près après les vacances de
printemps les parlementaires ont
retrouvé le chemin de l'hémicycle cette
semaine ambiance houleuse à l'assemblée
avec le grand retour du projet de loi
sur internet et le piratage quelques
tensions aussi au sénat avec la réforme
de l'hôpital et les manifs et puis
l'anxiété sociale bien sûr encore et
toujours les défilés du 1er mai sur fond
de crise et la gauche qui mène aussi
l'offensive au parlement nous le verrons
on va bien sûr parler de tout cela et
manuelles avec un député méridionale
proche très proche du chef de l'état
et oui notre invité c'est le député
maire ump de nice christian estrosi
bonjour bonjour on vous a vu récemment
avec le chef de l'état vous l'avez reçu
à nice pour un discours qui a repris et
développé le thème de la sécurité
notamment la lutte contre les bandes
alors le chef de l'état a pris un
certain nombre d'engagements qui vont se
traduire dans une proposition de loi si
vous qui allait la signer
c'est de la com ou faut vraiment encore
une nouvelle loi sur la sécurité
non on dit toujours c'est une fois de
plus ça n'est pas forcément une fois de
plus c'est une loi qui vise d'abord à
étendre des lois existantes pour les
adapter à l'évolution de la délinquance
qui est en mutation permanente et en
même temps à faire beaucoup de
prévention dans un domaine où si nous
avons obtenu des résultats de grande
qualité puisque sous l'impulsion de
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui président de
la république qui est ministre de
l'intérieur depuis 2001 c'est de près de
11% entre la délinquance a baissé dans
notre pays meilleur résultat depuis des
années en france et surtout des taux
d'élucidation qui sont montés de 25%
2001 à près de 37 % aujourd'hui
et alors nicolas sarkozy comme à son
accoutumée a décidé qu'il ne fallait
surtout pas baisser la garde et qu'au
moment où
voit que de plus en plus la délinquance
agi en bande organisée il faut de
nouveau apporter une réponse appropriée
ferme et juste ferme avec les voyous et
juste avec les victimes et les honnêtes
citoyens et vous serez son relais donc à
l'assemblée nationale alors votre
élection à la mairie de nice en mars
dernier vous a conduit à quitter le
gouvernement à ce moment-là vous
occupiez des collectivités locales vous
avez l'outre-mer de l'outre-mer pardon
vous avez vous êtes aussi un moment qui
fait déjà été vidé largement ces
territoires précis palace est pas
complètement faux vous avez aussi
disparu de l'organigramme de direction
de l'ump mais on dit que c'est pas une
disgrâce et qu'en échange on vous a
promis un retour au gouvernement un
nouveau portefeuille ministériel alors
vous confirmez je ne suis pas candidat
on ne m'a rien proposé je ne suis pas
demandeur vous savez seul le président
de la république en fonction des
situations et est à même de savoir à qui
il doit faire appel c'est tout je me
permets moi permettez moi simplement de
dire que moi je n'ai pas d'états d'âme
je n'ai que des états de service ça fait
25 ans que j'essaie d'accompagner le
président de la république dans son
parcours est qu'aujourd'hui
là où je lui serai le plus utile je
répondrai à son appel ex champion de
moto on vous a surnommé le motodidacte
et alors je me suis laissé dire que vous
préparez un livre qui aurait ce titre
alors là est ce que vous pouvez
confirmer je ne confirme pas je prépare
un livre c'est vrai mais nous avons le
titre est ma différence
j'essaie de démontrer comment un enfant
de la république fils d'immigré qui est
issu de classes populaires a pu face à
toutes les élites et particulièrement
celle de gauche qui sont toujours les
plus promptes à donner des leçons mais
dès que quelqu'un qui n'a pas le même
cursus universitaire que le leur
n'accepte pas qu'il puisse se hisser
dans l'ascenseur social a démontré que
tout cela était possible pour dire à
tous les jeunes de france
tout est possible dans notre pays quand
on attention christian estrosi on va
maintenant revoir on semblait temps fort
de la semaine commence bien sûr avec la
journée à 2 lundi la grippe porcine
affole la planète
c'est donc l'événement de la semaine
l'inquiétude qui s'accroît dans le monde
entier l'alerté à la grippe porcine ou
grippe mexicaine lundi le premier cas
avéré détecté en europe en espagne
l'union européenne déconseillent les
voyages au mexique et même aux
états-unis en france un important
dispositif est mis en place
and with or en aucun cas déclarés mais
la france se tient prête en cas de
pandémie grippale le matériel est
précieusement stockées pour faire face
au virus
on a actuellement 33 millions de
traitements de quoi traiter 33 millions
de malades sur les masques f les masques
ffp2 qui sont des masses destiné aux
professionnels qui sont des masques à
forte capacité de filtration
il ya un stock d'environ 750 millions de
masques pour les masques chirurgicaux
qui sont destinés à être donnés aux
malades
il y a aujourd'hui en stock d'un
milliard de masques le ministère se
refuse à donner toute information sur
les différents lieux où se trouvent
notamment le tamiflu
cet antiviral développé par un
laboratoire suisse est jugé efficace par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
depuis ce week-end une cellule de crise
a aussi été mise en place au ministère
il appelle les voyageurs et les
vingt-sept mille français résidant au
mexique à être très prudents mais la
france ne prévoit pas de dispositif de
quarantaine pour le moment les autorités
recommandent seulement une grande
vigilance en cas de symptôme grippal
une douzaine de spécialistes du service
général de la défense ont par ailleurs
été mobilisés dès vendredi
ce service du premier ministre suit
heure par heure l'évolution l'épidémie
c'est depuis le ministère de l'intérieur
que la gestion opérationnelle serait
assurée en cas de scénario catastrophe
mais christian estrosi l'inquiétude a
monté tout au long de la semaine comment
faire la part entre la précaution est
aussi la psychose
d'abord le gouvernement a pris des
décisions rapides cohérente et
coordonnée
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république nous savons que la france est
au plan sanitaire sans doute un des pays
les plus structurelles les plus
organisés et qui prend le plus de
précautions dans le monde face à ce type
d'événement nous l'avions déjà songé
mais qu' il n'y a jamais assez de
précautions
voilà il ya deux cas qui ont été
suspectés dans notre pays
nous sommes les premiers à voir lance un
appel aux autres pays européens pour
qu'il n'y ait plus de vols en direction
du mexique tant que nous n'aurions pas
complètement dit quel phénomène je suis
moi-même président du centre hospitalier
universitaire de nice un des plus grands
chu de france je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui que sous l'impulsion du
gouvernement
toutes les précautions ont été prises
pour que nous puissions éviter des
drames dans notre pays donc je dis à
tout le monde
soyez fiers d'être français et dans un
pays qui sans doute prévient plus que
les autres et nous permettra d'éviter
des drames
allez j'en viens maintenant climat
particulièrement tendu à l'assemblée
nationale cette semaine vous avez dû
bien sûr vous en rendre compte alors
petit rappel des épisodes précédents
juste avant les vacances de printemps
les députés s'étaient séparées sur un
gros bug pas assez de députés de droite
en séance à linverse grosse mobilisation
de la gauche
résultat le rejet du projet de loi sur
internet et le piratage alors après la
trêve des vacances cette semaine c'était
un peu la reprise des hostilités avec
par ailleurs un nouveau motif
d'affrontements le retour du débat
autour du travail le dimanche
rentrée houleuse au palais bourbon c'est
un sujet signé céline bittner éviter un
nouveau couac à tout prix
avec le retour du projet de loi création
et internet m dit pas question pour
l'ump le gouvernement d'offrir une
nouvelle victoire politique à la gauche
conséquence jean françois copé a écrit
aux 317 députés de la majorité pour les
mobiliser dans l'hémicycle est
aujourd'hui à droite on se dit confiant
sur l'issue du vote les socialistes ont
fait un petit coup tordu allez on se
cache derrière le rideau
et honnêtement nous on va leur répondre
massivement soutenant ce texte et sans
cacher nous mêmes des gens derrière le
rideau
parce que on n'a pas envie que le
parlement devienne un jeu de bataille
navale
mais les vacances ont-elles apaiser les
esprits pas si sûr
l ump certains comme lionel tardy
continue ouvertement de critiquer le
projet de loi contre le téléchargement
illégal et la gauche elle se dit prête à
continuer la bataille
une manifestation était d'ailleurs
organisé samedi devant l'assemblée pour
dénoncer le passage en force du
gouvernement
nous aurions pensé que le gouvernement
sache mans compte tenu du vote le 9
avril ne représente pas ce texte parce
que ce texte
en plus nous en sommes persuadés est un
texte qui remet en cause un certain
nombre de principes constitutionnels
un climat qui sera d'autant plus tendu
cette semaine à l'assemblée qu'un autre
débat revient sur le devant de la scène
le travail le dimanche
à l'automne dernier la proposition de
loi de richard mallié avait été reportée
sine aidiez raison le dépôt de sept
mille amendements par la gauche mais
aussi la fronde de certains députés ump
hier brice hortefeux annoncé le retour
du texte au parlement la possibilité de
travailler volontairement le dimanche
dans des zones bien définies était un
engagement du candidat nicolas sarkozy
cet engagement et des doit être tenu et
il sera atteint le dossier était bloqué
nous allons le débloquer une proposition
de loi sera déposée dans les prochaines
semaines et sera débattue en juillet
prochain au parlement l'opposition parle
déjà de provocation voilà on va voir
comment toute la semaine la tension est
allée crescendo entre majorité et
opposition parlementaire
oui lundi également les chiffres du
chômage très mauvais une nouvelle fois
soixante deux mille demandeurs
supplémentaires qui sont inscrits en
mars sur les guichets du pôle emploi
gouvernement le gouvernement prépare les
esprits à ne pas voir le bout du tunnel
avant 2010 le point avec henri bouvier
encore un mauvais chiffres pour
l'économie française
même s'il n'est pas catastrophique selon
la ministre de l'économie christine
lagarde
c'est en tout cas moins qu'en février
dernier le pôle emploi avait alors
recensé 80 mille chômeurs de plus
portant à 2,38 millions le nombre de
personnes à la recherche d'un contrat et
n'ayant pas travaillé dans le mois et
cela sans compter les départements
d'outre-mer et leurs quelques trois cent
mille chômeurs depuis le début janvier
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi est en
hausse de 250 mille personnes
et la barre symbolique des deux millions
et demi de chômeurs sera très
certainement franchi en avril
la situation n'est pas près de
s'améliorer des plans sociaux vont
continuer à se succéder comme à molex
continental ou à caterpillar
de quoi entretenir durablement
l'agitation sociale testing lagarde
l'admet il faut s'attendre à des
chiffres qui seront mauvais pendant un
certain temps car même si l'économie
repart ce qui est loin d'être le cas
il faudra près d'un an pour que les
patrons se remettent à embaucher alors
justement christian estrosi on a une
unité syndicale qui est retrouvée qui
est sans précédent depuis des années ça
illustre la tension sociale qui monte
le gouvernement n'a pas vraiment une
réponse à la hauteur de l'inquiétude
c'est d'abord ça traduit une inquiétude
qui est tout à fait légitime
c'est le rôle des syndicats mais je
crois que les syndicats sont tout aussi
conscient de tous les français que le
monde je dis bien le monde la planète
traverse une crise économique et
financière sans précédent
quand même temps la france est sans
doute un des pays au monde qui a pris
les mesures les plus énergiques pour
éviter un certain nombre de drames
par exemple des ministres la
présentation du projet bat pour la
formation professionnelle c'est bien
mais est-ce suffisant comme réponse en
matière de politique de l'emploi en
temps de crise oublier de rappeler
qu'avant il y a d'abord eu la protection
de lait des petits épargnants
1 je vous demande de regarder ce qui se
passe dans d'autres pays où cette mesure
n'a pas été prise et où les placements
des petits épargnants s'est perdue nous
il n'y a pas un seul français quelle que
soit sa condition sociale qui puisse
dire que son compte en banque n'a pas
été protégé qu'il ne peut pas les
retirer à quelques moments que ce soit
son argent première mesure deuxième
mesure est ce qu'il faut tout dire on va
parler simplement de la mesure de cette
semaine on laisse entendre que ça serait
la seule mesure qui était éprise un plan
d'investissement de 26 milliards d'euros
en matière de relance qui accompagnait
par les collectivités ou par un certain
nombre d'entreprises génère plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros
d'investissements dans notre pays
je prends l'exemple de ma collectivité
ça me permet par exemple à nice de
construire ou de réhabiliter en
logements insalubres
près de 3000 logements au lieu de 2 me
qui était programmé pour ne prendre que
cet exemple mais je pourrais prendre les
écoles les crèches les autres
investissements publi ça fait bosser d
achat prises également là achaque fois
c'est le donnant-donnant jeudi aux
entreprises vous vous engagez parce que
la collectivité grâce au soutien de
l'état fait l'effort conséquent à ne pas
licencier et qui plus est nous avons des
clauses d'emploi et de formation à
l'intérieur de nos procédures d'appels
d'offres qui impose aux entreprises qui
sont adjudicataires des marchés de
recruter de former des jeunes
donc on voit bien déjà que c'est une
mesure qui porte ses effets d'ailleurs
les chiffres que vous avez annoncé sont
déjà des chiffres qui baisse en termes
de diminution de la montée du chômage
par rapport au chiffre du mois de mars
précédant voir que tout cela est en
train de porter ses fruits
et enfin les mesures pour la formation
et notamment la formation et l'emploi
des jeunes qui ont été présentés cette
semaine le président de la république a
souhaité que tant dans l'investissement
dans la formation ou dans l'aide à la
consommation et au pouvoir d'achat
aucune mesure ne soit négligée c'est
sans doute pour cela que la france moins
que d'autres pays en europe subit les
conséquences de la crise allez place
maintenant à des images plus douce en
tout cas plus consensuel la visite de
monsieur et madame sarkozy en espagne
c'en est bien fini de la polémique qui a
agité les deux côtés des pyrénées
confère vous en souvenez bien sûr la
sphère ségolène royal et des propos
qu'elle avait prêté à nicolas sarkozy
sur le manque d'intelligence de son
homologue espagnol désormais grandes
démonstrations d'amitié entre le
président français et rossé luis
zapatero terrorisme basque immigration
clandestine trafic de drogue les deux
pays travailleront désormais ensemble
main dans la main et on va passer à
l'actualité de mardi comment empêcher la
désertion des hémicycles
et oui mardi ça chauffe encore à
l'assemblée nationale avec la
publication d'une enquête établissant un
classement des bons et des mauvais
parlementaire d'un côté il y aurait donc
les bosseurs dans l'hémicycle en
commission et de l'autre les députés à
la présence plus photo matic tout de
suite les explications avec julien
jacques un hémicycle presque vides des
députés absents c'est une scène que l'on
voit un peu trop souvent à l'assemblée
nationale qui sont les députés les plus
absents qui sont ceux qui travaillent le
plus un journaliste a établi son propre
classement tout simplement partir des
statistiques officielles du site de
l'assemblée nationale
vincent nouzille à relever notamment les
interventions en séance publique ou en
commission
on a relevé environ 140 nom de députés
qui ne cumulent au total que moins de
dix interventions en 22 mois ce qui fait
moins d'une intervention tous les deux
mois dans ce qui est quand même assez
peu donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
grande partie environ 150 députés qui ne
ce qu'ils ne font que passer et qui n'a
quasiment jamais que ce soit en séance
ou en commission donc cette analyse avec
d'activité ou d'inactivité on peut les
appeler les députés fantômes
parmi ces mauvais élèves on note par
exemple la présence de christian estrosi
jack lang ou jean tiberi mais le bonnet
d'âne revient à pierre bédier qui était
jusqu'à récemment député ump des
yvelines depuis juillet les moosehead
qui été élu député ump des yvelines qui
arménien cumulait on peut coller mais ce
tableau 0 interventions en séances 0
interventions en commissions 0 aux
rapports 0 proposition de loi zéro
questions écrites
je crois que le bilan était assez
parlants
demi même dans ce classement il ya aussi
les bons élèves c'est didier migaud qui
le premier de la classe
le député ps de l'isère totalisent 300
trois interventions depuis juin 2007
patrick ollier et pierre méhaignerie
complète le podium
alors quid des christian estrosi vous
seriez un député fantôme d'abord
permettez moi plutôt de remettre le
bonnet d'âne à celui qui vient de faire
le contraire
au journaliste qui est totalement
incompétent parce qu'il a bien rappelé
que c'est sur 22 mois
il a oublié simplement que je n'ai été
élus députés que le 26 mai 2008 c'est à
dire il ya 11 mois
je lui ai rappelé bien évidemment qu'il
valait mieux qu'ils le retournent en
classe pour passer son diplôme de
journaliste politique parce que quand on
ne va pas au fond des choses
alors que tout le monde sait que je suis
un des députés qui depuis 20 ans
parlement et des plus présents et les
plus travailleurs qu'ils multiplient au
moins sur 22 mois par deux sachant qu'en
tant que ministre d'outre-mer pendant
les onze mois précédent j'ai défendu de
loi de finances et lois sur la polynésie
et plusieurs métiers vous étiez au
parlement au-delà de votre cas personnel
bien sûr christian estrosi au le moment
où on parle beaucoup de revaloriser
parlement c'est vrai qu'on voit aussi de
nouveau apparaître tout le débat sur le
cumul des mandats est ce qu'il faut
citer sanctions financières pour les
députés où les sénateurs qui
effectivement ne sont pas assez en
séance ou en commission
quel est votre regard la tueuse est une
vraie question quand même mais c'est une
vraie question
mais la vraie question c'est aussi de
regarder au fond des choses
la présence des députés en commission
les auditions sur les rapports qu'ils
préparent leur présence sur le terrain
comparez un député qui habite dans le 7e
arrondissement et qui représente cette
circonscription et un député qui est au
fond de la bretagne dans le nord pas de
calais ou
au fin fond des alpes ou des pyrénées
mais il ya aussi le vous avez avec
l'exigence avec l'exigence et alors
qu'est ce que ça change d'avoir demandé
à partir du moment mais qu'est ce que ça
change
l'asip santé par exemple vous êtes
obligés d'être la moitié des recettes
est plutôt qu'à paris permettez
maintenant trois jours
d'abord le parlement ces trois jours par
semaine ne suis-je pas trois jours par
semaine à paris en même temps nous
voyons bien le texte de loi sur les
bandes dont j'ai été chargé un permettez
moi de vous dire que d'être le maire de
la cinquième ville de france qui est
confrontée au phénomène de bandes
organisées tous les jours qui doit
garantir la sécurité de sa population
qui est sans doute plus qualifiés que
quelqu'un qui sortirait d'une grande
école écoeuré été mis sur une liste en
cadre du non cumul des mandats et qu'il
aurait aucune expérience de terrain
serait sans doute moins qualifiés pour
porter un texte devant le parlement
comme je vais le faire c'est la vraie
qualification
c'est justement le bon équilibre entre
l'expérience de terrain et être un bon
législateur ça fait 20 ans que je suis
membre de la commission des lois et j'ai
la prétention d'être dans le domaine
législatif un des plus qualifiés au sein
de l'ocs rassemble et bien voilà pour la
mise au point très clair aller retour
maintenant notre grand feuilleton de la
semaine christian estrosi
le bras de fer entre le groupe ump
lauvaux ps de l'assemblée sur l'épineux
dossier de la loi internet et le
piratage la droite je disais tout à
l'heure n'a pas digéré l'affront de
l'offensive socialiste d'avant les
vacances
le ps je vous le rappelle qui avait joué
la sueur présence dans l'hémicycle pour
faire rejeter le texte de christine
albanel alors mardi jean marc ayrault et
jean françois copé s'affrontent de
nouveau
il est un peu à qui se posera le plus
comme le grand défenseur du travail
parlementaire
écoutez vous allez comprendre tout de
suite ça ne transpire pas vraiment
l'amitié la petite manoeuvre à laquelle
vous vous êtes livré le 9 avril dernier
discourtoise et déloyal bien contraire à
la tradition parlementaire a une
apparence celle d'une petite victoire
minable de votre groupe
pour une journée elle a une réalité
vous vous êtes payé pour pas cher une
belle quinzaine d' antiparlementarisme
et à quelque chose de d'inacceptable
dans l'attitude de monsieur copé qui
s'explique sûrement temps les députés
ump aujourd'hui on était temps c'est
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas là et
qu'aujourd'hui l'elysée vous regarde et
que cela vous tracasse et que cela vous
angoisse parce que comme vous allez le
faire sûrement pour le projet de loi sur
le travail du dimanche vous allez vous
soumettre aux diktats présidentielle
quelle drôle d'image tout cela donne du
parlement cristiano monsieur ayrault est
un mauvais acteur dans un mauvais rôle
il sait parfaitement qu'avec 19 députés
ils ont joué du feydeau ou en se cachant
derrière des rideaux dans ce qui est une
tradition parlementaire c'est-à-dire
qu'après qu'un texte était voté au à
l'assemblée nationale est voté au sénat
au terme d'une commission paritaire ou
en arrêter un texte global entre le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale
il y un accord pour qu'il y ait un
visage c'est de bonne guerre il est
normal en mai révisé le parlementarisme
quand on revendique à gauche d'avoir été
19 députés en séance sur près de 200 où
étaient les 180 autres ce jour là sur
cette tension cette espèce de guérilla
parlementaire qui est en train de
s'installer est ce que ce jeu l'ademe
qui m'attend ce on voit bien dans notre
pays il ya un espèce de climat de
violence dont la crise économique et
financière est pour beaucoup et que le
devoir des députés de droite comme de
gauche c'est d'avoir le plus de dignité
possible le plus de hauteur possible par
rapport à la situation
parce que nous avons besoin de rassurer
les français et parce qu'il y a des
temps dans la vie politique où nous
devons essayer de chercher des compromis
surtout sur des sujets aussi importants
que ceux là plutôt que d'afficher ce
type de querelles franchement ceux qui
vont bosser le matin ceux qui envoient
leurs gamins en classe en sachant qu'il
risque d'être menacé de raquette
d'agression et cetera
quand tu vois cette image le soir c'est
pas celle qui les encouragent ils ont
besoin de nous entendre parler de sujets
concrets et de recherche de compromis en
cette période de
crise après quand tout va bien on peut
peut-être se permettre quelques excès
mais là on était vraiment en danger dans
l'excès de la part de monsieur ayrault
après la scène qui nous avait joué il ya
quelques semaines de cela sur hadopi
allait aucun sujet rêvé de saison les
gens dit un mot qui sont les perdants
dans cette affaire ce sont les artistes
et les créateurs qui continuent à être
volé pendant un mois puisque la semaine
prochaine ça sera voté on aura réglé le
problème à cause de l'attitude de
monsieur ayrault et des députés
socialistes et communistes
soyez pas dans l'arve ans non plus c'est
du jamais vu dans le secteur hospitalier
c'est un autre sujet très sensible cette
semaine une mobilisation sans précédent
pour protester contre la loi hôpital
santé territoire
plusieurs milliers de blouses blanches
qui ont défilé à paris sous des
banderoles appelant à ne pas confondre
l'hôpital avec une entreprise le cortège
s'est même rassemblés devant le palais
du luxembourg au moment où les sénateurs
commençait l'examen du texte en
commission avec le souci de trouver un
compromis le récit de la journée
fabrice qu'une et c'est jean pierre
raffarin qui a tiré le premier jugeant
la réforme de l'hôpital trop confuse la
sortie de l'ancien premier ministre
sonne comme un avertissement pour
roselyne bachelot la majorité au sénat
ne votera pas le texte les yeux fermés
même constat du côté des centristes et
leurs 80 amendements
il faut que les médecins puissent avoir
une vraie participation gouvernance de
l'hôpital et panneaux un moment où on va
faire en sorte que leur choix est fait
face à ces dissensions valérie létard en
charge du volet handicap et dépendance
est venu faire de la pédagogie ce matin
d'abord au centre puis devant la
majorité reconnaissant à demi mots un
risque de fronde sénatoriale sur l'autre
partie du texte
très honnêtement encore une fois sur ce
champ là je ne peux pas vous parler du
champ sanitaire à la place de ma
collègue roselyne bachelot mais en tout
cas sur ce champ il ya un relatif
consensus sur la nécessité de
décloisonner les choses de ne pas agir
en parallèle alain milon lui et le
rapporteur du texte au sénat
il a passé une partie de la matinée avec
roselyne bachelot son rôle est essentiel
dégager un consensus sur le projet de
loi ce qui pose problème c'est surtout
la gauche
dans un hôpital et là le pouvoir des
médecins dans le cadre de l'organisation
administrative de pita ça va être le
travail de la commission de fédérer au
taux de base commune même à droite
aujourd'hui la contestation était encore
aux grilles du sénat et en blouse
blanche mais françois fillon et les
ministres concernés ont multiplié les
entretiens pour qu'elle ne gagne pas les
couloirs de la haute assemblée allez
j'en viens maintenant un sujet à la fois
grave et consensuelle la lutte contre
l'inceste à la une cette semaine à
l'assemblée la proposition de loi de la
députée ump marie louise fort pour
inscrire l'inceste dans le code pénal
un sujet que tant que je le sais qui
vous mobilise aussi un christian estrosi
alors tout de suite les explications
avec julien paquet
près de deux millions de personnes
victimes de l'inceste en france c'est le
résultat choc d'une enquête réalisée par
l'institut ipsos est publié en janvier
dernier un français sur quatre a dans
son entourage une personne concernée par
inceste
cette étude était une première en france
où il n'existe aucune mesure chiffrée
spécifique à l'inceste dans un rapport
parlementaire publié également janvier
la députée marie louise fort évoque pour
sa part le chiffre d'un million de
victimes devant ce flou statistiques
sont extrêmes recommande tout d'abord la
création d'une étude générale annuelle
l'objectif mieux évaluer le nombre de
personnes concernées
marie louise fort recommande aussi la
mise en place d'une véritable politique
de prévention par exemple le 119 numéro
d'appel pour l'enfance en danger devrait
être davantage mises en valeur dernière
lacune pointée par le rapport
l'absence de notion d'inceste dans le
code pénal et c'est sans doute cela le
plus important
les parlementaires souhaitent donc
inscrire l'inceste en le rangeant dans
la catégorie des crimes en 2005 un
rapport de christian estrosi sur le même
sujet n'avait été suivie d'aucune mesure
concrète
alors pourquoi on a attendu si longtemps
qu'à sion estrosi je ne peut que le
déplorer
bon en 2005 j'avais j'ai déjà dit
l'essentiel je suis un rapport où tout y
était sur la réforme du code pénal du
code civil et même du code des
collectivités territoriales donc un
rapport qui aller beaucoup plus loin
encore que ce texte qui est déjà grâce à
marie louise fort une grande avancée
gelé beaucoup soutenu
mais ni le garde des sceaux de l'époque
il le premier ministre de l'époque il le
président de la république de l'époque
n'avait souhaité que nous puissions
reconnaître l'inceste dans notre code
pénal autorise désormais sous les ors de
la république
sous ce premier ministre c'est chose
faite grâce à une initiative du groupe
ump
vous imaginez la satisfaction qui est la
mienne sur un sujet qui malheureusement
est encore un tabou dans toutes les
grandes sociétés dans le monde entier
alors que c'est un drame que c'est une
détresse qu une souffrance que subissent
d'abord des enfants mais des enfants qui
deviennent ensuite adultes et qui reste
traumatisé toute une vie entière et il
ya près de deux millions de personnes
recensées dans notre pays comme ayant
été victimes de l'inceste
eh bien je ne peux que me réjouir en
tout cas de cette avancée considérable
c'est un combat que j'ai mené depuis des
années et c'était une grande fierté
d'accompagner ce texte et de le voir
enfin reconnue dans notre loi voilà on
va passer à l'actualité de mercredi le
top départ pour la campagne des
européennes à droite
et oui cette fois c'est parti mercredi
matin l'ump considère avoir lancé sa
campagne des européennes la veille au
soir pas moins de quatorze ministres
autour de françois fillon à rueil
malmaison pour un premier meeting où
cette fois il n'est pas question de
manquer de sérieux sur la question
européenne michel barnier numéro un de
la liste et surtout sa numéro deux
rachida dati se montre volontaire et
précis germes andrieu le slogan une fois
lancé rachida dati entre en première
ligne avec xavier bertrand et michel
barnier hier soir toutes les figures clé
du parquet ont affiché l'unité
devant 1500 militants
à la tribune ce succès les ministres
jean marie bockel eric besson ou encore
hervé morin avec pour le moment un seul
objectif s'appuyer sur la présidence
française
nous voulons donc renouer avec une
europe politique
une europe politique ça veut dire le
volontarisme la plante et ça veut dire
aussi la responsabilité
voilà pourquoi les hommes et les femmes
qui vont s'engager dans cette campagne
doit avoir la même détermination
le même volontarisme et la même énergie
que nicolas sarkozy pendant la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
mais il est encore trop tôt pour livrer
le programme précis du parti le premier
ministre
attaquer l'absence de programmes de
l'opposition sans oublier de rappeler sa
position ferme sur l'élargissement notre
refus non négociable d'accepter
l'adhésion de la turquie n'est pas une
hostilité à l'égard de cette grande et
prestigieuse nation qui doit
naturellement être étroitement associés
à l'union européenne
seule ombre au tableau pour l'ump à six
semaines du scrutin les listes ne sont
toujours pas publié elles sont annoncées
pour début mai en même temps qu'une
liste de propositions concrètes
peut-être avant mardi ou nicolas sarkozy
en personne
lancera la campagne à nîmes lors d'un
meeting républicain
elles sont pourtant ces listes question
il se redit pourquoi est ce que ça prend
autant de temps
nous avons un bureau politique qui est
programmée le 7 mai prochain
et au terme duquel les listes seront
dévoilées nous aurons terminé avec la
phase investiture c'est largement assez
tôt un mois avant les élections que de
publier notre campagne quand même une
campagne si vous allez jouer gros on va
scruter bien sûr sur ses résultats des
élections européennes michel barnier
rachida dati c'est vraiment le ticket
gagnant
je crois qu'en ile de france puisque je
vous rappelle que nous nous adressons
tous les français vous ne parlez que de
l'île de france michel barnier était la
semaine michel barnier rachida dati sont
le ticket qui a toutes les chances de
l'emporter
ce sont deux grandes personnalités de
très grande qualité pour porter le
message de la france en europe et le
message européen en même temps c'est pas
ça écrase les emballages
à porter préjudice à la suite de la
france pour le montage qui a été fait
autour de ça qui est un montage à partir
d'un enregistrement fait par téléphone
et honteux rachida dati est un grand
garde des sceaux une grande personnalité
de notre mouvement avoir tourné en
dérision un enregistrement sur une phase
je dirais de distraction entre elle-même
parce que vous savez le côté humain le
choeur les changes la plaisanterie dans
nos rencontres avec les militants
c'est existe aussi c'était pas un
meeting officiel comme celui que nous
avons tenu à rayman maison c'est
pourquoi c'est honteux et je le dis il
faut arrêter il en va même de la
responsabilité des médias et de la
presse de ne plus tourner tout le temps
en dérision la vie publique
parce qu'un jour nous risquerions de
connaître de grandes déconvenues pour
tout le monde que ce soit pour la
crédibilité des médias comme pour la
crédibilité de la vie démocratique et
politique de notre pays
pour le reste les européennes c'est un
grand sujet on a sans doute le chef de
l'état qui a été le premier président de
l'union européenne au cours du deuxième
semestre 2008 a donné pour la première
fois de son existence une telle
dimension politique l'europe pour lui
donner un vrai sens et montrer la
capacité de l'europe face aux états unis
face à la chine ça c'est plus grande
souvient ça va jouer pour le résultat le
7 juin prochain les avancées corps a
permis nicolas sarkozy pour que l'union
européenne pèse de tout son poids
politique notamment au moment où nous
sommes entrés de plain pied dans cette
crise financière imposés là la
concrétisation d'un g20 et cetera
donc je sens des destinations et par
notre centre on non je sais l'échéance
européenne est toujours eu une échéance
difficile mais je crois simplement que
grâce à son action le président de la
république a fait prendre conscience
peut-être pour la première fois aux
françaises et aux français que
l'échéance européenne étaient plus
importantes qu'il de l'on pensait par le
passé à la société générale daniel
bouton s'en va mais sans les honneurs
depuis le début de l' affaire kerviel en
janvier 2008 le président de la banque
avait réussi à tenir un au départ même
avec le soutien de ses salariés et du
conseil d'administration
mais aujourd'hui ils poussent un ouf de
soulagement ses salariés à l'annonce
son départ marie brémaud il aura
finalement succombé aux multiples
scandales fragilisée depuis l'affairé
kerviel daniel bouton à la tête de la
société générale depuis 1997 démissionne
j'espère que pour la générale ceci va
clore un épisode charge et
d'interrogations et quelquefois de de
beaucoup d'incompréhension de la part
notamment des clients des banques
un épisode démarre il ya 15 mois par l'
affaire kerviel ou le grand public
découvre une fraude de presque 5
milliards d'euros imputée à ce jeune
trader
suivront de nombreuses maladresses comme
l'attribution de plus de 200000 stock
options aux dirigeants de la banque
alors en pleine crise financière
cela a créé une profonde rupture avec le
personnel qui n'a plus confiance et qui
a eu le sentiment que ces gens là ne se
battait pas dans l'intérêt collectif
mais uniquement pour eux pour garantir
le revenu un moment où l'ensemble des
salariés se trouvaient approuverait il y
à plus d'un an le chef de l'état
demandait au président de la société
générale de prendre ses responsabilités
c'est chose faite aujourd'hui
retenant les erreurs de communication
passé daniel bouton a bien fait savoir
qu'il partait sans indemnités
le futur retraité percevra tout de même
sept cent trente mille euros par an à
chaque président son grand chantier
nicolas sarkozy a trouvé le sien le
grand paris il a présenté lui même les
grandes lignes de ce projet c'était
mercredi
vous allez le voir c'est ambitieux avec
notamment 35 milliards d'euros pour les
transports tout de suite les
explications avec marie laëtitia
bouriège 35 milliards d'euros pour les
franciliens 35 milliards d'euros pour
redonner une âme à paris priorité à
l'environnement
paris sera la ville de l'après kyoto on
ne peut pas relever le défi de l'après
kyoto la ville durable en restant dans
les limites de sa seule collectivité
rien la ville durable ne peut se
concevoir que dans cette perspective
large où l'on peut inscrire une
révolution dans les notes de production
et de transport
misez sur les transports pour faire
respirer la ville mais aussi pour
révolutionner le lien entre paris et sa
banlieue
autre objectif du grand paris plus de
cohésion sociale avec la construction de
70000 logements par an la ville ne peut
pas exclure
elle doit unir parce que la ville brasse
les sages elles métis les pensées la
ville les cultures et la ville doit être
une chose de protection pour les plus
faibles
pour réussir le pari du grand paris il
faudra peut-être déverrouiller les
réglementations
parmi les annonces de ce jour nicolas
sarkozy veut relever les coefficients
d'occupation des sols
une page médias également dans
l'actualité c'est la nouvelle procédure
le prochain président de radio france
jean-luc hess a été entendu par les
commissions des affaires culturelles de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
les deux commissions qui ont donné un
avis favorable et puis aussi la
désignation par le président du sénat du
président de la chaîne public sénat
c'est donc gilles leclair 56 ans actuel
rédacteur en chef des services
économiques et politiques de france 2
qui va succéder à jean pierre elkabbach
et puis notez que pour la présidence de
lcp assemblée nationale l'audition des
candidats sera retransmise sur la chaîne
lundi 4 mai à partir de 14 heures
seulement et puis autre image ce
mercredi celle de ce camion publicitaire
circulant autour de l'elysée mais
également devant l'assemblée nationale
avec cette pancarte monsieur le
président trouvez vous normal que les
boucliers ne protègent que les riches
une offensive du ps à la veille de
l'examen de trois propositions de loi
socialistes dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée visant je cite à remettre la
france à leur juste injustement des
textes socialistes qui ont à nouveau
créé du rififi jeudi
le bouclier fiscal la rémunération des
patrons ou encore le délit de solidarité
voilà pour les trois sujets choisis par
le ps pour leur grande journée
d'initiative parlementaire jeudi le ps
présente sur ces trois thèmes trois
propositions de loi sauf qu entre
majorité et opposition les rancoeurs
sont encore et toujours là après le
fameux épisode de la loi internet et
piratage du coup vous allez le voir on
se rend coup pour coup et c'est au tour
de la droite de perturber le calendrier
de la gauche
explications avec anaïs coup battu le
parti socialiste vous l'êtes un rendez
vous social et la séance commence sur
les chapeaux de roue
l'ump explique sa stratégie au programme
obstruction parlementaire
aujourd'hui vous allez voir
tranquillement ce que c'est que
l'utilisation de procédures qui ne font
vraiment pas avancer le débat
des motions peut-être des demandes de
suspension de séance
peut-être décorum après tout nous qui ne
sommes pas d'accord avec vos
propositions on va faire comme vous
quand vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec les
nôtres au ce sera peut-être pas très
constructif
ça va durer qu'une journée mais comme ça
ça permettra à chacun d'avoir bien
gravée dans la mémoire une dernière fois
ce que c'est que ce système ancien que
nous voulons transformer c'est la leçon
de jean-françois copé à l'opposition et
les députés sont venus en nombre
l'exception d'irrecevabilité déposée par
l'ump a toutes les chances d'être voté
le débat devra alors s'arrêter et la
proposition de loi socialiste reporté
aux calendes grecques nous défendons une
proposition de loi vous avez le droit de
pas être d'accord avec mais accepter au
moins que les députés de mon groupe
puisse s'exprimer
ceux du vôtre aussi pour confronter nos
points de vue nos solutions
alors vous imaginez que pour nous c'est
acceptable que c'est une banalité que
c'est une péripétie parlementaire non
c'est une situation politique
particulièrement grave qui met en péril
le bon fonctionnement de notre
démocratie qui empêche que la colère
populaire
puisse s'exprimer ici non seulement
comme colère mais aussi pour y apporter
des réponses
le débat est plus que tendue les passes
d'armes entre les deux présidents de
groupes se succèdent
la séance est suspendue pendant une
heure et les tractations vont bon train
à la reprise les esprits semblent
apaisées l'ump retire sa motion de
procédure
le débat aura bien lieu nous retirons
notre motion de procédure afin que les
socialistes puissent discuter de ce
texte nous pour ce qui nous concerne
nous avons déjà tout dit et donc nos
orateurs bien entendu ne s'exprimeront
pas sur la discussion générale
nous avons déjà tellement de choses sur
le sujet et le sujet est sensible il est
question d'abroger le bouclier fiscal
réforme phare et contestée du
gouvernement les députés ump quitte peu
à peu l'hémicycle le vote solennel de la
proposition socialiste n'aura lieu que
mardi christian estrosi ou le savez bien
sûr le 6 mai prochain on va fêter les
deux ans de nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée
et ce sera l'heure d'un premier bilan
d'une certaine manière est ce que vous
ne considérez pas comme une chose
aujourd'hui qui pète un peu reconnue
comme jour des guillemets un échec c'est
ce sentiment que tous les parlementaires
ont de ne pas être associé à la réforme
et puis ce climat on l'a dit encore de
terre très malsain qui règne au palais
bourbon par le manger le président de la
république a voulu une réforme
constitutionnelle pour donner plus de
place au parlement
regardez en ce qui concerne le groupe
ump trois propositions de loi dans
l'ordre du jour partagé la première sur
l'inceste qui vient d'être adoptée puis
une loi sur l'emploi puis la loi de
lutte contre les bandes armées qui d'ici
à la fin de ce trimestre sera défendue
on voit bien la confiance que le
président de la république place dans le
parlement au parlement de savoir qui
sortait un livre cette semaine écrit on
sait que nicolas sarkozy un rapport
complexe avec les parlementaires il est
impatient il aimerait qu'ils aillent
aussi vite que lui pour voter les
réformes qu'il a annoncées revenait pas
d'accord et jean françois copé je pense
que le président de la république je dis
très clairement avec la plus grande
fermeté a réussi en moins de deux ans à
faire des réformes a rit ou on n'en
avait pas fait pendant 30 ans dans notre
pays avec le courage en tenant il vous
reste repas les permettant
la modernisation de notre pays aux plans
économique et social où nous avions tant
de retard et la plupart des
parlementaires du groupe ump qui ne
l'oublient pas on est élu sur le
programme et les engagements de nicolas
sarkozy plus que jamais affichent leur
unité autour du président de la
république donc pas de frustration
parlementaire j'en prends bonne note et
puis sans doute pour fêter aussi un les
deux ans de nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée
et puis aussi évidemment dans la
perspective des élections européennes
autre ouvrage cette semaine celui de
françois bayrou avec un titre choc un
abus de pouvoir
ça ne vous a pas échappé le président du
modem y dénonce une société des
inégalités croissantes totalement
contraire dit-il à l'esprit français
c'est-à-dire à l'esprit républicain
françois bayrou aujourd'hui vous
considérez qu'il est l'opposant numéro 1
nicolas sarkozy ont dit beaucoup qui
l'inquiète à l'ump
ce ton de donneurs de leçons ne me dit
rien qui vaille en réalité de la part de
monsieur bayrou qui était en quelque
sorte quelqu'un qui commence toujours
comme ça juste et qui termine toujours
comme bozo le clown mais voilà plus
dangereux comme adversaire que les
socialistes
vous savez il a un peu une une fière et
gothique on sent soigne aisément
remarquer un mais et c'est un virus qui
est agressif et tenace si on n'y prend
pas garde fait du mal
alors si son traitement passe par
l'écriture d'un livre ma foi après cette
fatidique grand bien lui fasse
jonathan je n'accorde pas plus important
ce que cela à monsieur berrou parce que
comme on dit tout ce qui est excessif
est dérisoire on va terminer avec un peu
de sourire quand même et christine
lagarde qui a fait le spectacle à la
télévision américaine invitée de jones
ou art sur le plateau de daily show la
ministre de l'économie s'est prêté de
bonne grâce au jeu de cette émission
satirique à la question de l'animateur
vous avez viré les banquiers des
banquiers est ce que vous ne voulez pas
en virer quelques uns chez nous
christine lagarde a fait un véritable
tabac avec sa réponse on écoute
pourri pourri de cette récession
économique catastrophique
du coup mes vieux clichés se bat france
aurait du sens de tout
mais non
les gîtes justin un dernier mot
là-dessus palestine estrosi
christine est magnifiques voiliers ou
qu'elles offrent cette image de d'un
gouvernement français autour du
président de la république aux états
unis avec cet esprit de détente
d'ouverture en même temps que le sérieux
qui lui appartient pas c'est formidable
il ya un anglais parfait d'américains
parfait la martinique fois en tout cas
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
acception estrosi d'avoir été notre
invité on va se retrouver bien sûr la
semaine prochaine avec emmanuel même
endroit même heure et qui sera christine
katrien partyka vice-présidente du sénat
ce message socialiste à la semaine
prochaine
ouais bon